Gracias Rafael por estar con nosotros
esta mañana de jueves en directo América
de Francia 24 un gusto Hola buenos días
un gusto vamos a hablar entonces de la
situación de las bibliotecas en
actualidad Cuál es el balance que le
podemos dar hasta este momento en un
mundo completamente digitalizado digamos
cada vez hay más
complementariedad entre la biblioteca
física y la biblioteca digital en el
caso de Bogotá por ejemplo tenemos la
biblioteca digital de Bogotá tiene más
de tres millones de recursos digitales y
junto con las 28 bibliotecas que tiene
la ciudad pues la gente viene utilizando
tanto la biblioteca física como la
digital el caso en Latinoamérica es más
o menos igual
y aunque muchas personas piensan que con
la pandemia las bibliotecas no se venían
visitando la verdad es que las cifras
demuéstran lo contrario cada vez hay más
personas interesadas y hay más espacios
bibliotecarios en las diferentes
ciudades digamos que esto también ha
evolucionado con el tiempo las personas
van a la biblioteca más allá
evidentemente para disfrutar de una
buena lectura pero para un estudio para
conversar Para qué se usan las
bibliotecas hoy en día no en la
actualidad de nuestro tiempo
digitalizado así es mucha gente piensa
que las bibliotecas están pensadas o
digamos diseñadas para procesos
educativos específicamente Pero la
verdad es que la programación cultural y
la programación comunitaria de las
bibliotecas es fundamental la gente se
encuentra en las bibliotecas habla de su
barrio de sus problemas hay actividades
y servicios como la alfabetización
digital y procesos que ayudan no
solamente en los en en el digamos en el
bienestar educativo de las personas sino
también en todo lo que tiene que ver con
recuperación de espacio público procesos
de paz y muchas otras actividades que
tanto en Bogotá como en otras ciudades
pues demuestran que las bibliotecas son
unos en una simple estructuras
culturales cada vez más vigentes en
donde suceden una infinidad de procesos
culturales Cómo hacer para que el
bibliotecas esté accesible para todos
Mejor dicho coma hacer una invitación
para la gente que nos ve o para todo el
mundo para que se acerquen a Estos
espacios No pues bien hay diferentes
maneras
los asuntos digitales ayudan un montón
porque hoy toda la programación cultural
de las bibliotecas está publicada en web
Ese es el caso de bibliored
efectivamente y al mismo tiempo la gente
sabe dónde están las bibliotecas más
grandes y muchas otras instituciones en
Alianza con las bibliotecas públicas
Incluso en instituciones tan grandes
como la UNESCO efectivamente tienen
presencia en las diferentes ciudades
realmente no hay en el caso por ejemplo
colombiano un municipio que no tenga al
menos una biblioteca pública comunitaria
Universitaria o público escolar
un poco es hacer la búsqueda y
encontrarla y de identificar las
bibliotecas como lugares de encuentro
cómo hacer para preservar y cuidar Estos
espacios tan importantes no Y también
Hacia dónde vamos
Pues hay diferentes maneras la mejor
manera de preservar y conservar es
utilizar los servicios de la biblioteca
acercarse a ella afiliarse a las
bibliotecas prestar los libros
registrarse en los diferentes
repositorios
digitales
y yo creo que vamos hacia unas
bibliotecas con servicios cada vez más
integrados en Red hay diferentes
instituciones con las que trabajamos
instituciones que no son solamente
culturales en el caso de Bogotá por
ejemplo con el sistema de transporte
público tenemos una alianza y con otras
instituciones creo que vamos hacia unas
bibliotecas que si bien pueden estar muy
digitalizadas siguen siendo lugares de
donde están los libros el conocimiento
de la antigüedad del conocimiento
moderno y bibliotecas que tienen cada
vez más servicios para la gente Cuál es
el desafío Rafael en nuestros tiempos
digitales para aumentar esta
presencialidad en la bibliotecas y que
de alguna manera no se vaya olvidando no
la importancia de ir a Estos espacios
para hacer vida claro realmente en el
caso de Bogotá por ejemplo nosotros
tenemos los fines de semana una
presencia muy activa de los grupos de
familias porque las bibliotecas también
están en lugares donde hay parques hay
diferentes actividades culturales y
entonces ayudan a ese proceso de
encuentro yo creo que la la posibilidad
de acceder también a recursos digitales
que a veces muchas personas en
Latinoamérica no tienen en sus casas y
en las bibliotecas pueden encontrar una
conexión rápida internet equipos de
cómputo y demás son otras opciones para
acercarse a las bibliotecas Y
definitivamente la con ciertos
conversatorios charlas discusiones sobre
memoria local y actividades como como
esas
generan la esperanza de que las
bibliotecas seguirán siendo sin duda
vigentes como nos dice Irene Vallejo en
su libro Qué tipo de eventos culturales
visita o le interesa más a la gente que
hayan en Estos espacios Pues los jóvenes
visitan sobre todo Distrito gráfico
manga los los universitarios y los
investigadores visitan las salas
generales también los repositorios
digitales los niños para los niños
siempre tenemos un espacio especial en
todas las bibliotecas y normalmente
venimos trabajando también espacios para
madres con niños en primera infancia a
madres gestantes y demás esas alas son
particularmente visitadas los auditorios
sin duda son unos espacios muy muy
frecuentes en las bibliotecas Y por
último pues está un poco la idea de que
la biblioteca no es solo el edificio
donde están los libros sino también la
extensión bibliotecaria muchos procesos
bibliotecarios como en el caso de
bibliored llevamos los libros hasta
donde está la gente a los parques al
sistema de transporte masivo y a muchos
otros espacios Entonces pues no la idea
es encontrarnos el libro en todos los
lugares de la ciudad Rafael ya va para
finalizar es una región tan complicada
como la nuestra América Latina del
Caribe con tanta desigualdad Cuál es la
importancia de biblioteca para generar
como esa cultura para generar también
espacios de paz en la sociedad crear una
sociedad más sana sobre todo en las
generaciones futuras digamos hay un
asunto fundamental en las políticas
públicas relacionadas con bibliotecas y
lectura que tienen que ver con el acceso
al libro en Latinoamérica tenemos
todavía un trabajo importante por hacer
en el acceso cada vez hay más libros
llegando a las diferentes lugares y esa
es una manera en la que Esperamos que
los índices de lectura en Latinoamérica
suban un poco más nos acerquemos a los
síntesis del resto del continente o
eventualmente los índices europeos y
entremos en diálogo con otras culturas
con otros tiempos
esa Esperamos que sea la manera de
también de colaborar en la construcción
de paz y sin duda por las bibliotecas
como lugar de encuentro ayudan
considerablemente en el reconocimiento
del otro en entender y tener empatía por
migrantes por procesos de recuperación
de violencia por procesos de
reconfiguración sociales los barrios y
ahí las bibliotecas han tenido en su
historia un papel fundamental hemos sido
lugares de vacunación de entrega de
alimentos y esperamos seguirlo siendo un
lugar para la comunidad para disfrutar
de todos Así es Gracias Rafael como
siempre por su tiempo por estar con
nosotros esta mañana jueves en directo
un abrazo igualmente